hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
februari the force today and your change
into gamespot news snotty dog seem to be
having a hell of a time trying to get
uncharted 4 to run at 60fps that's his
game director Neil druckmann assessment
is anything to go by he told Game
Informer that attempting to get the game
running at the high benchmark framerate
is in his words really hard drachman has
continued to say that it's an optimum
experience at 1080p that they're aiming
for which may or may not come at 60
frames he explains the objective for us
is just to make the best experience and
right now we're trying to push the look
then we'll see where we're at and
reassess we're constantly making choices
to our production about what's going to
make the game feel best and look its
best a slew of rise of the Tomb Raider
details came in the door today and
here's what we know then you game will
feature a traumatized Lara
understandably who is now super in term
it's about immortality and ventures
across Siberia looking for answers
Crystal Dynamics have described all
sorts of natural hazards Laura will
encounter from the weather kind to the
lodge and furry kind basically Laura
gets back from her year-long nightmare
holiday from the first game and funnily
enough nobody's really on board with her
claims that there's a sun-worshipping
cult and an immortal beings as for the
game's mechanics crafting will still be
a big thing there are still a variety of
environmental puzzles and it seems as if
there might be some sort of day-night
cycle and reading terms of course
because tomb raider Destiny's newest dlc
pack house of wolves has had a bunch of
its details leaked and I'm going to tell
you about them so if you want to be
surprised to note now all the findings
i'm about to share with you were dozen
mind and posted on reddit by an
anonymous japanese player according to
the lake house wolves with programs to
be unlocked on me
19 but that one could easily have been
changed the dlcs overarching story
description reads the Queen's fallen
have purchased their freedom with a
working blood hunts down the traitors
and your debt to the Queen will be paid
so mostly killing things then shocking
the expansion offers a storyline dealing
the games are working race a new
exclusive raid three new crucible maps
and a new strike featuring fallen
enemies which appears to take place on
the moon level according to a leaked
image on top of that this obviously
heaps of new weapons armor and gear
bummed you say they don't want you to
put too much stock in the potentially
outdated info but do as you will let me
know down in the comments which game
you're anticipating most rise of the
Tomb Raider uncharted 4 or destinies
half of wolves dlc you can also find
more news on gamespot including a story
on GTA 5 sales and condemned 3 those are
all the good things that I have for you
today let me know what mattered to you
and I'll catch again same time tomorrow